walkabout to camera with me joshing
chasin today we on this studio of my see
Paula Quan Smith we're super excited by
your aces collection his name you are
gonna bring glamour to the masses
absolutely my aesthetic is all about the
body accentuating the waist points
curving out the hips yeah so when you
put this on when you zip this up the
woman is going to feel completely
snatched completely sexy notch and that
was that's the that's the whole goal of
wearing laQuan Smith what would be the
ultimate date night look for ensuring
that you're giving the lad you're on a
date wave the green light I think this
is a perfect first date moment it's body
con it's stretchy it's comfortable it's
a mock neck it's mini so you can show up
those great legs this is actually a nod
to a very iconic moment in my career
when I dress Beyonce the laQuan Smith is
not just for celebrity that is not the
message the message is that any woman in
the world at any age at any race at any
size can put on a look once with the
dress and have the celebrity effect
that's the feeling I want to go back to
the days when women actually sit dress
up if I was gonna go to the Christmas
party not me personally I was a woman
what would be the ultimate conversation
piece over the Christmas party said I'll
show you right now she's giving holiday
she's giving beadwork look at this look
how stunning this is it's heavy number
one number two it had a lot of secrets
to you about it's it's all hand-beaded
it's boning all on the inside so when
she's zipping this up her whole waist is
gone I mean this is actually one of my
favorite pieces in the collection and I
think this is the perfect holiday dress
now what I also really love about you is
you do resample representation and
representing all people from body sizes
different races sexualities how do you
feel that the fashion industry's evolved
since you first started out you know I'm
very happy to see in terms of models you
know that there's been a lot of great
representation with you know skin color
with sizing you know I think as far as
designers is concern
I think that we still have a little bit
more to go I would love to see more
representation you know in terms of like
the luxury design world you know but I
think that you know I think that the
fashion industry has made its efforts in
terms of diversity and inclusion but I
think there's also other you know ways
and practices that we can we can do to
move forward if anyone out there is
watching this and they feel like they're
lacking confidence going in to the party
sees in what p.m. a mantra do you want
to tell them find out your your best
assets your best cut you know find out
what makes you happy have fun don't take
life so seriously it's about that moment
when you zip up that dress you put that
makeup on you put that shoe on and
you're like damn so it make sure you
look in the mirror girls tie yourself
down I look good and you're good to go
[Music]